bueno es realmente importante porque se
confirmaría debemos el primero de los
objetivos regionales de esta misión
especial que han establecido los rusos
en el que buscar el control total de
tanto lugares como de danielle así que
ya estaría cumplida la primera parte y
todo indica que se tomaría la región de
dones en relativamente poco tiempo para
las expectativas de ucrania y de sus
aliados occidentales la toma de hecho
decisión tomó menos tiempo de lo que se
esperaba porque los rusos están tratando
de cruzar un río que separa a cero en es
desechado y les haya tomado su tiempo
pero lo han conseguido y hoy tener una
concentración de fuerzas muy grande por
lo que es esperable que tomen
el resto de la región en menor tiempo de
lo esperado lo que hay que ver ahora es
si ese avance va a ser este
causado por algún tipo de ataque
ucraniano como se dio y bélgorod que es
territorio ruso
y traten de hacer divergen digamos los
objetivos en el terreno lo cual no logré